today we're going to be speaking with
sheila alechi who is a reporter with
icij and also coordinates the
organization's partners in asia and
western europe
thanks so much for talking to us today
thank you
so
my audience has certainly heard of the
pandora papers we've reported
i don't know about extensively but we've
reported about the pandora papers for
people who maybe aren't familiar with
what these documents are how do you
generally summarize what the documents
are
well i would say that pandora papers is
an investigation based on a leak of
about 12 million documents
confidential financial records coming
from 14 different
financial service providers from around
the world from the most secrecy
secretive jurisdictions including
seychelles cyprus bvi and so forth and
what these documents tell us
is how the offshore financial system
works but not just that also how the the
global economy in a way works because
the system that thrives on secrecy
and
anonymity is basically a big part of the
global economy right now
and
some of the biggest headlines related to
individual prominent individuals
politicians elected officials
functionaries of other kinds well-known
people
um
i i don't know if secretly is the right
word but certainly behind the scenes
using a lot of these other other
mechanisms and instruments for their own
personal finances is that a fair
assessment
i think so what we found was that uh
more than 300 politicians including more
than 30 current and former uh country
leaders used shell companies and
offshore trusts to hide wealth
from their own citizens as well so
public
elected officials
such as the president of kenya the king
of jordan
the then prime minister czech republic
and other prominent politicians um used
this kind of structures to
hide wealth or buy
real estate around the world and um
obviously we have to be careful here we
don't want to say that all of this is
illegal
much of this actually is a legal and
legitimate but the problem here is
actually that
it allows um
people to avoid scrutiny um and so it
can be used um
by um you know husbands who don't want
their divorces to know about their
assets um as well as criminals who don't
want authorities to know about their
assets
how does the icij um obtain these
documents to the extent that you can
talk to us about the process
yes we don't comment on our sources
we obtained these documents and
what we did initially was
fact checking most of them and trying to
figure out whether they were actually
whether they were accurate and where
they were
you know fake fake documents and
the way we do this is a process that we
have learned to do over time because
this is not the first offshore financial
project that we do
we obviously check the leaked documents
against public records
we always
involve journalists from many different
countries who have the expertise and the
sources who allow us also to verify the
information whether it's true or not and
as you know we don't publish we don't
publish the whole data set because there
are confidential information and also um
you know information that is may not be
true so um we try to um you know go
publish publish only stories that we are
able to verify and um and um also ask
comment for yeah i wanted that was going
to be my next question about asking for
comment in many types of stories
uh when someone is written about you ask
that person for a comment there's a
deadline they have the opportunity to
say something or to say no comment or to
not even respond at all
here
the the story is really the documents
and if the documents are accurate
the concept of a comment is a little bit
different right because it's basically
do you what exactly are we asking for
when we ask for comment about a document
well we want to know the context because
sometimes you don't have the story in
one document you may know that one
person set up a company and that's it
you may know what it is for sometimes
you don't even know what the purpose of
this company is so obviously we want to
know we also want to know the purpose um
for example if it was for tax reasons or
not um and then obviously you know we
also want to um just give the
opportunity to anybody um to
to say to have their say and um seij
alone we are about 15 reporters and
editors on staff and we sent more than
400 comment requests just for this
investigation excluding all the requests
that our partners
have sent so every name that is
on our story
we will will be
you know fact checked and
they will have the opportunity to
comment now out of the 400 how many
chose to comment well i don't know the
exact percentage but i must say that
what i've noticed
is that over time people especially
politicians have developed a very good
strategy and most of them did not
respond or did not respond adequately or
they chose not to respond to our
questions and wait for after publication
to go on their social media and facebook
and you know give their own opinion
there directly to their
followers
you mentioned that a lot of what is
revealed is not against the law
but it can be used in ways to
circumvent reporting requirements or
there's a lot of different ways in which
these mechanisms can be used how much of
of the investigation is
talking to lawyers about
is there anything illegal here and
highlighting the illegal
a lot a lot of because we are
journalists we are not experts obviously
we've been doing this for many years so
there are some basic um
you know concepts and knowledge that we
have but at the same time you also want
to be sure that you know
you are up to date with the
most recent legislation or regulation
etc and also here we talk about
hundreds of countries so each country
has its specific regulation and after
panama papers which is an investigation
we did in 2016 um some laws changed so
you also want to be sure that what
you're reporting now is um obviously up
to date um so
yes we we love experts um
and
they are they they always help us
understand um
the context
sometimes when we have teams reporting
teams from many different countries we
also have experts from many different
countries who kind of um tell us what's
going on
so for this i want to give a little
context for my next question in the
united states certainly and i think this
happens in other countries too whenever
there's a leak of information
if you like the content of the leak you
focus on the content and you ignore how
the documents were obtained if you don't
like the content of the leak you ignore
the content and you say how dare they
get these private documents you focus
only on how it was obtained
when we're talking about banking records
i mean there certainly are
privacy laws and different countries
have different rules the same as with
medical records with with banking
information
how does the icij
think about
that at the end of the day these
documents are
presumably documents that are are
believed to be private documents and how
what is the sort of ethical approach to
that
so first of all whenever we publish a
name or a story we always ask whether
it's in the public interest so i'm not
going to publish my neighbors you know
banking records nobody cares about that
but i do care about a politician i do
care also about a powerful business
person who may have a political ties or
any impact on a community um
obviously i do care about criminals so
um that's some ethical um discussion
that we you know we have always have
before uh publishing anything um and
then again you go and ask for comments
so you don't do it behind the the back
you know like you always um try to
confront the the people that you're
writing about um so it's not a surprise
um and
when i say we go to co for comment we
have um
you know we we ask about at least five
weeks before publication so that we
can always ask at least three times
um calling i have sent for example last
time i sent
an email uh not an email a registered
mail to myanmar you know because
there was only a physical address that i
could use and you try whatever you can
are there um are is this the type of
investigation where for your team
there are physical security concerns for
the reporters that are doing the
investigating
so lucky
icij's team most of it is based in the
u.s or in europe
but of course we work with journalists
from around the world and uh you know
from russia
hong kong for example arab countries and
we have a lot of and also in latin
america many latin american countries
have freedom issues so um
more than the ics staff obviously we're
always concerned for our partners and we
work with them every day we're always in
touch so if there is an issue for them
we try to to help them for example one
thing that we do is if a partner cannot
publish a story in their own country
there may be a partner in a neighboring
country that can publish that story for
them so that the person or the reporters
in trouble can report on something that
has already been reported without
exposing themselves so we try to so
that's why collaboration is great
because it also help protect each other
um and especially people in you know
more vulnerable vulnerable situations
whenever there are these these big leaks
and revelations
um there's the question of okay so what
is the ideal
consequence or outcome
with you know you look at the edward
snowden nsa leaks and there are a lot of
people who said well the the outcome
should be now that people have been made
aware of these techniques
those should be changed they should be
made illegal or you know there's kind of
like a clear path what's the goal here
is it sort of international
tax and finance policy reform or what
would be the outcome that would be an
ideal outcome
well surely transparency is something
that we will hope
to have more around the world you know
and after panama papers for example some
countries introduced laws to
for example reports record the
beneficial ownership
and so forth and every time obviously
that we do a project like this new
loopholes emerge for example this time
something interesting had to do with the
us and what we learned was that while
smaller jurisdictions for example like
bahamas were trying to improve their own
system uh huge and you know economies
like the us that were actually becoming
um the go-to place for people to hide
money um and so this time we really hope
that if the us that actually step up and
improve
their own regulations
when it comes to people like elton john
jackie chan you know shakira named in
the papers
talk to me about the public interest
there and to be clear i'm not saying
there is no public interest it seems
different than an elected official that
might influence policy however so i'm
curious about the public interest when
it comes to entertainers you know um
i understand that there is a difference
between a politician an elected official
and a pop star but at the same time
these people have a lot of influence
even if it's just uh um
you know on people a lot of impact on on
every everybody um and so they kind of
like they they chose a public life in a
way and so obviously um
the their their finances um if obviously
if we find something that is worth
reporting um then that can be um you
know um put on scrutiny um at the same
time we always go and ask for comment
and so for example um there were a few
of these um celebrities that
came back saying that they had done
nothing wrong and um which we also
reported like models etc um
but you know this is a system that
rewarding
that we want people to understand why it
is significant at the same time whether
if while it is legitimate um in some
cases you know you still have tax
revenues that are lost
so we want the public to be informed and
whether it's a politician or a celebrity
that contributes to the system i think
it's still worth talking about it
well it's it's an incredible
investigation and i encourage uh people
in in my audience to
go to the icij website and there's so so
much documentation there we've been
speaking with sheila alechi who is a
reporter with the icij
i really appreciate your time today
thanks so much for talking to us
thank you